[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
i'm going to keep my intro short because
i want to jump straight into the
conversation my guest today is edward o
thorpe he is the author of the
bestseller beat the dealer which
transformed the game of blackjack his
subsequent book beat the market
co-authored with sheen t kasoof
influenced securities markets around the
globe he's also the author of a man for
all markets subtitle from las vegas to
wall street how i beat the dealer and
the market thorpe was one of the world's
best blackjack players and investors and
his hedge funds were profitable every
year for 29 years he lives in newport
beach california and his website is
edwardothorpe.com
ed it is so nice to see you and thank
you for making the time
pleasure to be here tim
i've enjoyed many of your podcasts
well it's lovely to finally connect and
perhaps we'll get to the
the tiny concentric circles and small
world that connected us at some point
but i thought we could begin with a
little bit of background for people who
may not have
the
entire context and then we can fill in
the gaps so perhaps you could speak to
a little bit of your growing up and your
formal education
if you wouldn't mind
i was uh born in chicago
during the reign of herbert hoover
president number 31.
so i've seen 16 presidents
i moved out to california with my
parents during world war ii
and basically grew up in
california went through
junior high school and high school out
here
and then went to
uc berkeley and ucla and i got
a
bachelor's degree
and a master's degree in physics
and then
in the middle of my phd
for physics i
realized i needed more math so i started
taking it and then i saw i could
graduate more rapidly in mathematics so
i got my phd in math instead
and then i went on to teach at ucla
mit
new mexico state university and finally
university of california irvine
now how did
gambling or interest
in
those types of applications of physics
or mathematics enter the picture for you
well i'm a curious person and you could
say that it happened purely by chance
when i was teaching ucla
i got interested in
beating blackjack somebody
told me about an article
that
would let me let me play almost even
so
one christmas vacation my wife and i
went out it was
actually christmas vacation of 1958 when
i
just after i got my phd we went out to
las vegas and i never gambled because i
knew it was a
loser for most people
and the odds were against you but i i
bet 10
and i played for about 40 minutes and i
had an interesting experience the first
20 minutes i had a little card telling
me what to do and people thought i was a
fool who uh knew nothing about the game
and
they were right that i knew nothing
about the game but the card made me much
smarter than the other players
and so
i made some remarkable plays that
attracted their attention and then they
all hovered around they wanted to see
how i was making these plays and one of
them i got a
seven card 21
which
is very rare
and in most places paid a bonus they
didn't pay moments in this particular
place but they thought i was trying for
that and i somehow managed to produce it
so i realized they didn't know much
about the game really and i went back
and
read carefully the statistics article
and realized that i could see
from my math background
how to actually
devise the system to beat the game so i
then i i set about to do it
and
about that time i
moved from ucla to mit and i had access
to the big computers
at mit this was back in
1959 they had an ibm 704 which was a
refrigerator-sized machine that served
30 new england universities so i taught
myself how to program
and as i worked my way through with my
ideas i saw that
i had a winning system and it was just a
matter of finishing all the calculations
so i went ahead and did that
and
then i
wanted to find out
i wanted to get this
system published because i thought that
from my experience in mathematics and
what i've seen happen elsewhere
other people would claim they did it and
grab the credit
and i
that annoyed me because it already
happened to be mathematics a couple of
times
so
i went shopping for somebody who could
get me quick publication
and
turned out that on the mit campus
there was a man who i knew nothing about
named claude shannon
who was
an institute professor and he was a
member of the national academy of
sciences
so he could get me
if he approved of what i wrote a quick
publication in the proceedings of the
national academy it would only take a
couple of months to get it out
so i looked him up
one day and
the secretary at mit's math department
said there's no point in going to see
him he doesn't see people
he's very private and if you do get to
see him you're only going to have five
minutes
so
i i finally managed to see him at lunch
for five minutes
and uh after we talked
he said well looks like you've got all
the main ideas here yes i'll put this
through but we have to change the title
the title was
a winning strategy for blackjack
and
he changed it to something like
a favorable strategy for 21 which
sounded better
he didn't want to make too bold a
statement for the national academy
and make it look like
this was a just a gambling paper
so anyhow the paper got sent in
and it caused a sensation because i had
submitted an abstract to it to the
american mathematical society meeting in
washington dc where i was going to
present
by the way
they initially rejected the abstract
saying that this is just another fool
with a system that doesn't work because
we know you can't beat gambling games
but
on the abstract committee was a
person i knew well from ucla a number
theorist named john selfridge
became quite well known in uh number
theory and he said well if thorpe says
it's true it probably is so you should
accept this abstract
so i went there and i presented and i
thought there'd be about 50
mathematicians in the audience but
instead there were
300 people it was jammed
and a lot of people were very odd
looking they had pinky rings on and
sunglasses and
tropical shirts in the middle of winter
so
after i finish they lunge for my uh
little handout i brought 50 handouts
thinking that's all i would need there
and i
basically tossed the handouts out and
left as quickly as i could
then it was picked up by a fellow named
tom wolf who became a famous american
novelist
and he wrote he was a young reporter
then he wrote a piece for ap which
went across the country and so it got
massive press
and that led to me writing a book
and
telling everybody how to do it after a
couple of years
between the time i wrote the book though
and when i told people how to do it by
publishing
i went out and played blackjack myself
and
proved the system worked
i figured that there's no point in
writing a book unless i knew it really
worked i knew it worked in theory
but what if you actually tried to do it
and you know a lot of things they seem
to work in theory but when you get down
and actually put something to the test
uh you find out there are all kinds of
things you didn't think of
turned out in this case
it worked very well
we made uh
in one weekend with a test eleven
thousand dollars which
is about that with a zero on the end uh
in today's money
this is in about 20 hours of serious
play
so i had
a lunch money at mit for a very long
time thereafter
ed let me just jump in for a moment so a
couple of questions
i i could have a thousand follow-up
questions but i'll just i'll limit it to
a handful the first was for that 11 000
which would be
say 110 000 in today's dollars
20 hours of serious play do you recall
roughly what the
the bankroll was or these the starting
capital it was ten thousand dollars oh
that was the starting okay got it we
started and we have an eleven thousand i
see got it on top of that so a little
more than doubleton
and my prediction before we went was
that that's what would happen
so it panned out all right two other
questions
rewinding a bit to your earlier story
when you were when you were first
sitting at that blackjack table if i
heard you correctly you said you had a
little card
if if i heard you correctly could you
describe what was on the card
yeah it was a set of rules for
hitting and standing
doubling down and pair splitting and it
was the
best way to play
with a higher degree of approximation it
was the best way to play against a
full deck
or what was left of a randomly shuffled
deck if you didn't know anything more
about the cards that have been used up
and my contribution
after i
understood this was to figure out what
would happen when
some of the cards are missing from the
deck
because
the cards that are used up are not
a representative sample of the cards in
the deck they can vary quite erratically
for example you might use all the aces
early and that would be bad for the
player or you might use none of them up
uh until late in the game and that would
be quite good for the player
and with claude shannon
the person who doesn't meet anyone you
said you were able to get five minutes
at lunch why were you able to get time
with claude
or why do you think he he was willing to
spend time with you
it turns out that he was willing to
spend five minutes i think probably just
to get rid of me but after we talked he
kept asking me questions and it became
15 minutes
and then he approved the paper that i
wanted to submit and then he said what
else are you working on
so i said well there's another project
which actually i started before
blackjack and which got me interested in
gambling
and that's a way of beating roulette
and claude shannon it turns out was
probably the king of
gadgeteers he built many ingenious
machines over the course of his life
he built
robots that would run mazes machines
that would play chess
he
just
loved all that sort of thing and he had
a house full of
gadgets and equipment hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth in
money
valued and money back in 1958 59
so when you hear it about roulette and i
explained to what my ideas were there he
got very excited so we continued to talk
and this
five minute meeting became
half an hour and then an hour and then
we
adjourned to the
cafeteria at mit to grab a bite
and we went on for another couple of
hours
and we decided that
we would
join together and make an all-out effort
to build a
machine
that would allow us to predict the
outcome of a roulette game
and turned out and that the i'm sorry go
ahead
no i was just going to say the house
and casinos have had to i was going to
say adapt but really
counteract
your strategies and tools by changing
the rules um so could you say more about
what what you then devised
in the case of roulette
well what we did was we built a
small
computer that would had about
11 transistors in it
11 or 12 i don't remember which because
we had two versions and
i forget whether we ended up with the 11
or 12 transistor version
the computers now at the mit museum in
cambridge that's been on exhibit in
various parts of the world at one time
or another
in any case
over about a nine or ten month period we
worked in shannon's basement almost full
time and we
we built this
wearable computer
turned out to be
the first wearable computer according to
the mit media lab
and
one person would wear the computer and
enter
push button information about the
position and velocity of the ball
and the rotating
wheel in the center
and then the computer would instantly
there's a trick there i do mean
instantly it would instantly tell you
where to bet
and so
the other person would sit at the
roulette table apparently not connected
with the observer who was busy putting
in the
roulette information
and that person would hear a series of
musical tones
and when the musical tone stopped
the last tone in the octave would tell
him
what section of the wheel to bet on we
divided the wheel into eight sections
with a little bit of overlap
and so
the person who bet which happened to be
me was
able to quickly put down
money on five
neighboring numbers on the wheel
and had a massive edge of 44 so
the
piles of dimes we started out with with
our experiment uh dime chips became huge
piles of dimes very quickly
so the computer worked wonderfully well
then i want to take a step back just for
for people who are listening and say
that
there are many reasons that i wanted to
have this conversation with you and
it is not specifically related to
gambling in the sense that what most
there are many things that interest me
about your life and your thinking and
my hope is that for people listening
they get a window into at least two
things one would be
your methods of thinking frames and
works for thinking how you think about
thinking and then also
your
personal approach to
health
and fitness and because as people may
have picked up with some of the
references
could you tell everyone listening
what your age is as we speak today
i'm 89
and for those people who can't see video
you look like you're in your 60s and i
am just
beyond excited to to hop right into that
so we're going to jump around quite a
bit we want to do this exactly
chronologically but
could you
perhaps describe
your approach to
health and fitness and you could you
could tackle that starting wherever you
like is it just that you were
given the right parents and out of the
box have tremendous genetics is there
more to it how would you begin to unpack
this
i kind of wandered into health and
fitness by
accident initially just like i wandered
into blackjack and roulette i'm curious
and always looking for
things to understand and
i like the idea of self-improvement too
so
i i was walking uh behind the student
co-op one night when i was about 20 and
heard a bunch of clanking
i looked down in the basement and there
were some
fairly burly guys down there
pumping iron and i walked in and i said
you know this is this is a waste of time
this is ridiculous so one of them said
to me i'll bet you a milkshake that if
you work out with us for a year just
one hour an evening three evenings a
week you'll double your strength in
a set of exercises that they uh
describe
so i said i don't believe it let's try
it
so i went down and the four exercises
were
the squat
with
a barbell on a rack
the military overhead press
the bench press
and uh deadlift
own deadlift no i wasn't dead left it
was something else
i forgot the fourth one at the moment
but i'll think of it clean and jerk
maybe who knows or bent row
yeah
it was something along those lines but a
compound exercise like like the others
yeah so there was a fourth exercise so
anyhow
what happened was
i
i was a uh
i wouldn't say 98 pound weekly but maybe
a 150 pound weekly
and at the end of the year i could
military press 185
which was
at least double what i started with
i could bench press 375
i could do 15 at
325
and i could
squat with 375
i could do sets
and
forget what the other one was
i wish i could remember it in any case i
was astounded that all this uh came to
pass
so it made me pay attention to uh
uh strength at least
and some time went by
and i a little swimming because i got
interested in scuba diving and then uh
one day in my
30s i was jogging along the beach with
my
brother-in-law
and he said let's go for a little jog i
went for about a quarter mile and i was
gasping i was 35 then i remember
i
i said this is awful i'm in terrible
shape i have to do something about this
so they had a book on aerobics by
somebody named ken cooper who has a lab
down in texas and started
in large part the aerobics a revolution
that swept the country
so i started keeping track of his points
he gave you points for
various degrees of aerobic effort i
think if you
did a mile in
between 12 and 15 minutes you got one
point and you did between
10 and a half and 12 you got two points
and so forth
so i started trying to run a mile a day
and i did that
well i ran a mile every saturday to
start with
and then
one saturday i just had to try a little
further so i ran two
and then three
and then i said i'll i'll try a 10 mile
race
so i got another 10 mile race which was
kind of foolish
but
i finished and i did i did reasonably
well so then i said i'll try a marathon
so then i got into marathon running and
i really like that i did that for about
20 years until i uh hurt my back
weightlifting
all my bad events have been from uh
pushing myself athletically
so hurting my back was probably the
worst single thing the herniated disc so
i had to stop had to stop heavy pounding
heavy running
but
20 years of road running
and uh well more than that maybe 25
years and a marathon
gave me i think a very good base for
going forward and so now i
do things like i'll walk about
three miles
three or four times a week and i spent
about two days in the gym doing
stretching and
uh the strength exercising
core strengthening and so on a lot of
emphasis on core because of my back
which is just fine now
i was just going to ask how your
approach seems like it has evolved and
and
changed over time say after 50 years of
age or yeah in the i mean in the last
say 40 years or so are there any
particular changes that you made in
addition to the core
strengthening to support the back that
you think have
contributed to your longevity i've
evolved i try to listen to my body
so
i do what i enjoy
and
the rule i started to follow was some is
better than none
and more up to a point is better than
less
so there's there's no excuse i mean
if you tell yourself gee i'm not going
to do this because i can't do the whole
program that's a big mistake just start
doing it and i find that if you start
doing it and you get used to it you find
more and more things that you kind of
like that you can build on and then you
just keep getting better at it
i was probably in my best shape at
around
55 to 65 because of all this
wow that is
that is inspiring i am just about to
turn 45 and
even amongst my just to say age cohort
it's very
common for me to see people giving up
even in their 40s and blaming it on age
but with you sitting in front of me
describing your trajectory and sort of
adaptive habits
i feel like those
those excuses don't hold a whole lot of
weight
is there any other advice
one thing that's pretty neat is uh
race walking i did that for a while and
that's something that is lower impact
than running
but you can get the same kind of aerobic
workout
so that's something i'd uh direct people
towards
what does your strength training look
like
now uh or over the last few decades
as i get older it declines i get weaker
and it gets a little harder to do things
and i i feel a little tired i can't do
as many
reps or sets of things
so
i have a mix of things that i do now i
will
do
squats
and usually now just body weight
and i try to i'll do dumbbell squats
or
lunges with a lot of emphasis on
one leg and then shift and do a lot a
lot of
weight on the other leg
do pull-ups
and
i think the best i've done recently
which is not very much is uh four
underhand pull-ups and two overhand
pull-ups
i used to be able to ten years ago i
could do a dozen of each
and
let's see what else
well i do
a lot of back exercises regularly
on the mat and that's very helpful for
keeping my back in shape and keeping my
core
in pretty good condition
so we may come back to this but let's
let's
segue
and go back in time yet again
and
look at investing how did finance or
investing
enter the scene for you well the way i
got into finance and investing was that
i made money at blackjack and from book
royalties
and so i had this first time in my life
i had any spare money before that as an
academic my wife and i were living from
month to month with no surplus
and then kids were coming and that made
it even tougher
so
once i had some money from
both gambling and book royalties
i wanted to figure out what to do with
it
and so investing made
good sense to me i would put some
capital aside and let it grow
i started out by making
a lot of foolish beginner mistakes which
cost me
and then i decided to sit down and
really figure this thing out
and so i began to study
investing in my spare time so i spent
the summer of
1964
which was
i guess the third year i was in new
mexico state
just reading all summer
in a big bookstore in
beverly hills uh martindale's reading
all the investment books and newspapers
they had
and then i started again in the summer
of 65
reading whatever i could find and i
happened to get a little book on
warrants
common stock purchase warrants which
were the forerunner to what people call
call options now
and
when when i saw that a light came on and
i realized that i could mathematicize
this and i could figure out how to value
these things
and if i did that i'd probably be ahead
of the crowd who didn't know how to do
these things and so i'd probably have an
edge
by chance i came to uc irvine when it
opened in
the fall of
1965 and i was telling one of the deans
there
about this idea that i had and that i
was working on he said oh we have
someone else who does that
and turned out to be uh sheen casuf
and so the two of us hooked up and she
and kasoof had actually been doing it in
practice and he'd already made
an elementary model for trying to
judge warrants
so we decided to write a book together
and work out
more of the details and theory
and so that became the book beat the
market
and that launched
both of us into separate uh businesses
and so i began to
do what i call warrant hedges
and basically you buy a cheap warrant
and you short common stock against it
that's one way or you buy an overpriced
warrant
and
you short it up i said buy you short an
overpriced warrant and you buy the
common stock against the hedge the risk
because they tend to move together
and when
in the case of the overpriced warrant as
it collapses toward zero or toward its
uh conversion value you capture an
excess return and what i found was that
you could make a steady
25 a year with practically no risk doing
this
so i was doing it for myself
and then word spread around
the uci campus and people wanted to sign
up so i signed up the dean of the
graduate division and i also signed up
the
secretary to the chancellor
and some people in the math department
and so forth so i was managing a whole
collection of
little
accounts for people and they were making
25 a year and they kept telling
everybody about it
and the dean of the graduate division
happened to be an investor also
with a fellow named warren buffett
and warren buffett was uh at that point
shutting down his partnership because
everything was overpriced back in 1968
prices were crazy
and
the dean of the graduate division wanted
to know where to move his money to
so he introduced me to warren buffett to
kind of check me out to see if i might
be a good place to put it and so warren
and i got along fine and apparently i
passed the test because the dean gave me
his money to invest
and so i got to know warren buffett
and i was sorry to see that he was going
out of business because i thought
as i told my wife then this is going to
be the richest man in the world we'll
come back to the that a little later
uh i think you'll find uh the follow-up
to that quite interesting
so i know
i got the idea of forming a hedge fund
from
a warren buffett who was just closing
down his hedge fund
and
so i went into business
managing
accounts and then merged the accounts
into the hedge fund
and started this hedge fund or private
limited partnership
and
that ran for about 20 years and used
ideas that i kept generating
mathematical finance ideas to keep
staying ahead of other investors and
making excess returns and
in
20 years we only had three down months
out of all those months
and those down months were less less
than one percent so basically just
printed money every month
and it made just under 20 annualized
during that time
so there was a i'm very risk averse as
you you'll find as we continue to talk
and so this thing ran with extremely low
risk but yet had uh very high return
so that was my entree into investing
that's one hell of an entree
20 to 25
annually uh let's let's touch on a few
points here
so there were
two other people
who i believe read beat the market or
were influenced by it fisher black and
myron shoals
could you could you just perhaps fill in
the dots with uh with that because
nasim
refers to the black scholes model
with a different name
could you perhaps just
fill in the gaps there for people who
are listening
i actually
figured out what this model was back in
the middle of
1967
and i decided that i would just use it
for myself and then later i kept it
quiet for my own investors the idea was
to basically make a lot of money out of
it for everybody
and it was fun to me just to develop it
and apply it to various things
now fisher black and myron scholes read
beat the market which was sort of the
launching pad for me into finding this
model and it was also a launching pad
for them
and they they saw how to
improve the ideas and beat the market
and they made
a
mathematical finance model
that value warrants and options very
accurately
so
it was based on a
set of assumptions that are
fairly narrow but pretty good
and i thought that i was the only one
who had this model
so
when the chicago board options exchange
opened in 1973 i thought i'd have the
feel to myself but
unfortunately fisher black and myron
trolls
published the idea
and they did a better job of the model
than i did because they had uh very
tight mathematics behind their
derivation
i had to make a couple of assumptions to
get to the same
point but they're reasonable assumptions
which i've turned out to stand up in
practice and in theory later on
so in any case they published the model
and i thought oh
i have this a hedge fund i've been
running for a few years it's been doing
well we're going to make a lot of money
in options but now
scholes and
black and trolls have told everybody
what the secret is
but
people didn't catch on right away so
when the chicago board options exchange
opened for business in april 1973 the
only people on the floor were my traders
and they were busy
it was like
having machine guns against bows and
arrows
for people who don't know shoals went on
to win the nobel prize for economics in
1997. yes and a black would have been
there too if you hadn't died of
cancer before that
yeah
and robert merton was at mit where
they've been
doing a lot of good theoretical work on
the development of warrants
and options and so
he wrote some beautiful papers about uh
this theory about the same time that
black and trolls were doing their work
so
the prize was awarded jointly to
merton
and scholes
and
i will say this about the prize
the people who publish are the ones who
get the prizes
the people who don't publish it doesn't
matter what they figured out when they
figured it out they don't get the prizes
and in a sense they don't deserve to
because
if you don't publish you haven't really
proven to the world that you really did
this on the one hand and you haven't
really changed the world in the same way
that people who published you
so
i think the people who don't publish
don't have claims to these prizes
having having the tool in place turned
out to be revolutionary for my life
because i was able to
use this tool and i had some
shortcuts in using it that other people
didn't have for a very long time
because i developed it myself beforehand
and they didn't get around to seeing it
the way i saw it these shortcuts were
very useful we stayed ahead of the
marching legions of phds who came later
we stayed ahead of them all the way
through into
the atomic closeman partnership in 1988
let me hop in for a moment here to
ask ask a few questions about your
meeting or at least one with warren
buffett why in that meeting did you come
away saying you thought he would end up
being the richest man in the world what
did you see or hear or observe in that
meeting that led you to that
i saw that he was
compounding at a higher rate at a high
rate of return
that he'd been doing it for a long time
he was very very smart
and that he really knew a tremendous
amount about companies
so he was a good uh evaluator of
companies
so he he had this and he demonstrated a
very large edge already he'd been
running his uh partnerships from 1956 to
1968
and had about a thirty percent before
fee annualized return rate
and i was sorry that he was going out of
business and that
things looked so bleak from the
standpoint of
stock pricing to him at that time
the interesting follow-up to that story
what warren buffett did at that point
was
he
decided to make
a
poor textile company
in uh i forget where it was uh somewhere
in new england
called berkshire hathaway he decided to
make that his own little mutual fund a
private mutual fund and he bought up as
many shares as he could
and
he didn't
particularly encourage his exiting
partners to take shares in that company
because he wanted them himself
they did have a choice they could take
cash or they could take shares in
berkshire
and
not knowing
what to do
many of them just took cash and exited
some of them took berkshire though
for sure i think was they would have
gotten it at something like 12 a share
in 1964.
now it's
a little under 500 000 a share
so oops the berkshire store is kind of
interesting
i knew how smart he was and i said the
way he's compounding he's going to be
my opinion the richest man in the world
in a while it'll just take time
and uh
i lost track of him i figured he was
just working for his own account and
there was no opportunity for an investor
that was that was largely the case
but then back in uh up in 1982
i happened to see an article about uh
berkshire hathaway and i saw that he was
running it
and then i decided to take a look and i
said oh
it's gone from 12 to 982.
so
is the opportunity gone many people who
owned it had sold on the way up taking
their enormous profit of a multiple of
five or ten or fifteen
and
i said i know what he's doing i know i
know this man i know what he's going to
do i'm buying at 982.
even though
i missed out the move from 12 to 982 and
of course buying 92 turned out to be a
good move
yeah i would say so
let me ask you
if you were teaching
a
[Music]
let's just say
what could be undergraduate or graduate
seminar in investing now
so
you're teaching a class of
neophytes
how to invest
and some are
say mathematically inclined and some are
not it's a very mixed group
what types of tools or thinking
frameworks heuristics
mental models
anything would would you focus on in the
first handful of of lectures
the first thing i tell them is
the answer is really easy for almost
everybody but you're not going to
believe me until you work through
yourself and understand it and i'll tell
you the answer to start with and then
i'll try to convince you that it's the
right answer so i'll just tell you the
answer to start with
the answer is if you're a long-term
investor you should just buy and hold
equities
and the best place to have bought gold
equities has been the u.s for the last
couple of hundred years overall
equities here have compounded at
about 10 or 10 and a half percent for
200 years
the data for the first hundred years is
not as good as the data for the last
hundred but the data for the last
hundred is quite good and uh very very
well documented
how does that do against everybody else
well
you can prove
by logical and mathematical arguments
and i won't go into all the details here
some of it's in my book it's also in
other places you can prove
that
if a person
simply buys the index and holds it he
will outperform
most of all the other players
and he will simply up the people who buy
and hold the index will beat
the whole collection of people who don't
do that
they do way better on average the ones
who don't do that
pay
trading costs
they have
more volatility from diversification
generally
from lack of diversification
and they often pay investment advisors
and
all this and they also pay taxes when
they trade
so the upshot is that you might make ten
and a half percent if you don't pay all
these people
you might make eight or seven or six
percent if you pay the crowd of people
waiting to
quote help you unquote
so
that's the simple answer for people who
don't know anything about investing now
you might say well yeah but i'm pretty
smart i hear all these stories i listen
to kramer on tv jumps around makes a lot
of noise and sounds good
so
why can't i do better
well the academics have something called
the efficient market theory in which
they claim that you can't do better
now i've already
explained that that's that's wrong you
can find instances where you can do
better warren buffer
apparently did much better i found with
my hedge fund i could do much better
but the
kind of work you have to put in to do
much better is substantial
it doesn't seem like it at first but
when you get into it there all kinds of
details and follow-ups and things to be
checked out and you end up spending a
substantial amount of time and energy
figuring out how to do it better
and
for everybody who finds out how to do it
better
the rest of the crowd who isn't
buying the index
is doing a little bit worse because you
can show that the whole collection of
people who don't buy the index are
themselves
as a group like the index
because everybody is a group is like the
index
you subtract the index part out and the
rest is like the index too
and
so
the people who
aren't buying the index but are like the
index as a group are busy paying all
these costs
taxes
investors investment advisors and so
forth so on average
that whole group does worse so you're
starting you're paying basically uh
casino vigorous or whatever if you're
not uh indexing and you've got to beat
that in order to do better than the
indexers and obviously
the group can't beat it can't beat that
so
it's only a small uh collection of
people some by luck and some by skill
who end up doing better
so you're basically betting against the
odds if you just step in and buy stories
and invest in various uh
mutual funds that are actively managed
and so forth
so that's what i would tell people now
now on the other side of the coin
if you really are interested in
investing it's worth educating yourself
and trying to do it because you will
learn a lot about investing you might
actually find a way to win
and you'll learn about
how the world works and a lot about life
too
the things you learn from what seems
like a narrow specialized field
generalized very widely to all kinds of
things if if you're the kind of person
who can take a lesson in one part of
life and
transport it to another part of life
what are some of those transferable
lessons
in your mind
well let's take risk as a good example
you learn about investment risk
and how
you want to avoid
very great risks or minimize them
if you take that
because
great investment risks can take you out
of the game altogether
so you might have a thing where you
multiply money by 10 times but you might
also lose it all
some things that are via highly volatile
like buying cryptocurrency
are in this category where you
you may have the chance of a very large
gain but also the chance of a very large
loss and if you lose most of your
capital it's very hard to climb back out
for instance
if you lose 90 percent of your capital
you've got to multiply what's left by 10
in order to get back to even
which means you've got to make 900
percent to offset that 90 percent loss
that's not going to be easy to do it
takes a long time so you want to avoid
really bad outcomes
so
i applied that for example to
covet
i thought about
uh
what to do and how to deal with it and i
said
you know at my age the stats that came
over early 2020 showed that people 85
and up
were
dying at the rate of
if they were male 18
of those who got it
and
even now the death rate is very high for
those who get it if they're unvaccinated
it's probably pretty close to that and
if they're vaccinated it's maybe attempt
that
so
i consider that a risk that can take me
out of the game with a fairly high
probability so i'm going to avoid
getting covered if i possibly can
i'm going to mask up i'm going to avoid
crowds
i'm going to think about what the risks
of various activities are that i do and
decide whether it's worth it
so i
did a my own analysis of covid and its
risks and
tried to be very careful from then on
and i think it's i think it's paid off
and
it's paid off for my family too i've
passed this information on to people
around me
do you have any recommendations for
and this might sound a little meta but
how people should think about
long term thinking or the long term
because the
the recommendation
for
say an
equity index or
index etfs
was
predicated on
investing and holding for a long period
of time what would you consider the
minimal viable long period of time
if you have an answer to that and and
how can people become more aware of
their own
weaknesses related to
short-termism or short-term thinking and
switch to more long-term
i tend to be a long-term thinker you
might say oh if you're 89
how can you be a long-term thinker
well i have children and grandchildren
and
i also i'm feeling pretty good and
staying in good shape so i
89 may not be all that old at this point
in any case
i would say that if you're looking out
15 or 20 years or more
maybe you have a
dynasty trust or something like that or
you have descendants and you yourself
expect to live 15 or 20 years or more
the best investment i think is to buy
almost entirely equities and hold it you
might have want to have a little cash
around
but
i think a buffett recommends 90 index
and 10 percent bonds or
short term intermediate term bonds for
cash
that that does just about as well as 100
equities i just put it all in equities
because i have enough so i don't worry
about fluctuations up and down
if you have a shorter time horizon you
may want to do things differently
and it depends on how much you're going
to need and how much you have
i have a set of rules that are a little
bit helpful here
there's i'll start with what i'll call
the four percent rule
suppose that you're going to retire
and you want enough
to last you
from your capital throughout the rest of
your life i would say a pretty good
working rule it's put most but mostly in
equities
and spend four percent of your capital
each year
or less if you can
and that ought to last you from say
the 60s till the end of your life
it's not guaranteed but pretty good
chance it will
then i have the two percent rule
which i found by
studies both mathematical and by
simulation of
stock returns
if you
only drain two percent out per year
then
that money will probably grow in
perpetuity there's a small chance it'll
be extinguished by really bad downturns
but very small
there
is an organization that
freezes people and they ask me for
advice about
how to invest their endowment fund
freezing me meaning cryogenic people
and so i said
for the endowment fund
which is going to get people out of uh
being frozen sometime in the far future
50 100 200 years out but that fund
you're going to want to invest long term
and let it run because that's going to
get you the most money down the road
and
if you're going to attempt to reanimate
somebody
there's no
specific timetable if you don't have
enough money to reanimate them at a
certain time you can wait a few years
and let the money grow a little more
so you want money to grow
to as big an amount as possible in the
far future and so
the
two percent rule for the endowment fund
i think was a pretty good rule for
spending because all the simulations
showed that it would grow to a very
large amount over a period of time
so
that's long-term thinking an
intermediate term i think of that as
maybe
5
5 to
15 or 20 years
and
there something like the four percent
rule that i described might be good
and for short term it's just a matter of
what your needs are and what you're
going to have to
come up with
and
people are in various uh ranges of
wealth there's what you might call poor
where
you don't have very much uh to save or
put aside and you're gonna be hard hard
to retire and hard to make it
then there may be middle class people
who can put a moderate amount away i
know somebody for example she has saved
about a million and a half
and she is in her mid 50s
i think she'll be fine
so i've explained to her pilot all in
equities and let it rip she gets scared
every so often when there's a downturn
she calls me and i tell her
just
hold fast and then it goes back up she
said i'm really glad i held fast
a lot of people are what i call scared
rabbits
and
when the mark goes up
they get confident they start buying and
then it drops they get really scared at
the bottom and they sell out
and then it goes back up and they buy
again and it drops they get really
scared at the bottom and they go back
out again so they seem to have the worst
of it all the time
it doesn't feel good to go through life
as a scared rabbit
and it's and certainly it certainly
hurts your
financial standing that's where thinking
for yourself comes in yeah you won't
hold fast to something unless you
understand it yourself
there's an old saying
give a person a fish and they eat for a
day
teach a person to fish and eat for a
lifetime
and there's a similar thing for thinking
if you give somebody advice about a
problem they might solve that one
problem
if you teach them how to think about
problems they can solve problems for the
rest of their life
and so that's the way to go
and also if you give them advice and
they don't know understand what the
advice is or how to think about it it's
a good chance they won't take their
advice
i'll give you an example
back in 1991
i was invited to
review the portfolio of
mckinsey and company back in
new york
and so they had a profit sharing and a
pension plan
and i came and i uh looked
at all the things they had and the
things they had were really quite good
but there was one very strange
investment they had it printed out
one or two percent a month every month
they've been doing it for years they had
a record going back into the late late
60s supposedly
and i said how do they do this
and
they said well
we don't know exactly they tell us that
they won't explain what their method is
but we can show you our accounts so i
looked at their accounts
and
i saw that
this account
bought stock
and it
put
option positions aren't called callers
they had a put option a little below the
stock price and they bought a call
option a little bit above
and that
the two things paid for themselves was
self-financing
so they didn't have apparently a whole
lot of risk but i could show that in a
down market they would lose
in a down month in an up month they
would win but they won every month
and the reason they went every month
was because
a mysterious trade was put on
involving s p index options and it was
always in the right direction
so if they were going to lose it would
be a winner and if they're going to win
it would be a loser
so i said this is this is not possible i
said i want to go over and look at this
place
so they called
the person in charge who happened to be
at that time peter madoff the brother of
bernie madoff bernie was off in europe
raising money this is 1991 mind you
and
so when peter madoff heard i was coming
he said no i won't i won't let him in
the front door
so i held my nose and i said i want to
take a better look at all this so i
looked at all their trades and i saw
that
half the trades never happened when i
researched them
that is there was
no trades occurred on any exchange at
the prices they were making them at for
these options
another
quarter of the trades
had
so much volume
that
the volume couldn't have happened
because there wasn't that much volume on
the exchanges where they traded
the last quarter of the trades
which consisted of 40 or 160 to start
with the last quarter of the trades
didn't happen anywhere there was no
explanation
so i said okay let's
look at some of the trades that actually
could have happened
so i went to a vice president of bear
stearns
rest in peace
and
[Music]
said you know we do a lot of business
together
i'd like to ask you a special favor
which you might or might not be able to
grant
i'm going to give you 10 options trades
i'd like to know
who was on the other side of these
trades
in particular was
made often company on the other side of
any of them
so they researched the trades and they
came back and said no can't find any
trace of any made often company
so i said to mackenzie
this is the fraud
and they said but we're making 20 a year
i said well you're making 16 of your
currently in your other investments
would you rather
if i'm right
this 20 is not real and the roof is
going to fall in someday and
you might lose your jobs
on the other hand
if i am right
and you move
you have saved this problem
if i'm wrong and you move you're only
going from 20 to 16
so you know it makes a lot of sense to
just
exit so they exited in two months
we inquired of everybody we knew i threw
my network day through their network to
find out
who had investments with madoff and how
much they had
now we could only cover a small part of
the territory because our network was
not comprehensive
and it turned out that
about
half a billion we were able to identify
now
that means that there was a lot more
than half a billion out there how much
more we couldn't say
but things were looking very bad
on the other hand how could you
challenge madoff he was a pillar of the
national association of securities
i think he'd been a
past president he'd been
on committees there he was the biggest
third market that is not the exchange
maker in the country
so
a respected person
and uh well known to everybody and he
had thousands of investors as it turned
out and because he had so many investors
everybody knew it had to be right
because surely those people had checked
it all out
now
finale of the story is that when i was
doing this the person who invited me who
was a hedge fund manager himself
who invited me to
do this for mckenzie he had been an
advisor to them
this person
believed and made off
continued to go out and raise money for
him
and in 2008 when the news came out that
madoff was a fraud
my son called me up and said you know
dad the stuff you've been telling me
about for 17 years it finally happened
it blew up
so anyhow this fellow who had been
running a fund of funds and included
madoff in that fund of funds they were
it's a special type of hedge fund that
invest in other hedge funds he had been
doing this and had a very big fund to
funds
he was raising money
for madoff the same week that the bad
news came out
and he had his own
personal money
and his family's money and trust fund
money with madoff
but i had explained everything to him in
great detail i knew him quite well at
the time back in 1991 that
mckenzie and company had
had this analysis explained to them and
decided to pull out
so the whole point of this is here's the
person who had all the information
it was explained very clearly and he
just
didn't believe it
and he himself was in the investment
business and was very successful
but
he was a reporter
in times past
and
his family made a lot of money
in the 30s he was
came from a rich family in chicago
and the way he figured things out was he
would pull people
and he would ask
people what they thought about something
it would be like i asked you um what's
the uh best diet pill i can take you'd
probably say there aren't any good ones
and i'd probably agree with you but uh
right he'd ask a hundred people and then
they would in fact be a pole and he'd go
by the pole
so
just imagine that you
asked
10 000 people
whether they thought
you could travel faster than light
and all but one said
yep you can do it
i saw it on tv
and only one guy said no you can't do it
albert einstein
so
a guy like him would overwhelmingly
reject einstein and believe the the 10
000 average people who uh just said yeah
you could do it
because the poll was
9999 to 1
on one side
so he doesn't think for himself he lets
he lets the crowd think for him
and
that i think is a fundamental mistake
that many people make they let the crowd
do their thinking they don't figure it
out for themselves
so let's let's talk about toolkits and
bring in we don't have to focus on him
necessarily but
since warren buffett came up earlier
you have then his partner charlie munger
who is well known for
mental models and i think buffett
describes him as having the best
60-second mind he's ever met something
like that
what
mental
models do you find helpful or
would you teach in that class that i
mentioned earlier
and you can really approach it in any
way that you think is
is sensible but
how should people
think about mental shortcuts or mental
models and are there any that come to
mind that you think are particularly
valuable i'll tell you about a few
and i'll tell you where to get more
perfect
let's take
a notion that economists call by their
priestly name
externalities
have you heard of that term i have i
have heard the term okay good most
people have not as it turns out so
you're
you're way ahead already
well i'll see where we go
an externality simplistically is
a consequence that's
of somebody's action
that's generally not intended and it's
usually bad
but it's sometimes good i'll give you
examples of each
of varying sizes
here's a bad one that happened to me
actually last week
i go out to get my car and i find out
that the tires flap
i look
and i see a sheet metal screw
in the sidewall
which means that
this tire is going to have to be
replaced
so i end up taking care of the problem
where did the problem come from
most likely i think
down the road from me there's been a lot
of construction going on
i've noticed as i go for walks that
pieces of metal
are often lying in the road sheet metal
screws nails
other things that aren't good for tires
i think i'm up when i happen to walk by
but i don't get them all
and the workers are curiously
depositing more not very many but it
only takes one to give me a flat
so
this is
an unintended bad consequence of the
work going on there
who benefits
well the homeowner does because he
doesn't have to police his guys to clean
up carefully and sweep the streets
afterwards he doesn't have to spend
another
five dollars a day on sweeping labor to
make sure that none of these things are
there but it cost me five hundred
dollars for a new tires unfortunately
it's a tesla plaid with a ten and a half
inch wide michelin tire so the tires are
not cheap
so
this is an unintended bad consequence
for me that saves a very small amount
for
the guy who's doing the construction a
few doors down let's take
a little bigger one
when i was a chemistry
student back at age 14 in 1946
teaching myself i mean there was wasn't
a decent chemistry class around
i came across a fellow named cevante
arenas
the great swedish physical chemist from
the latter part of
the 19th century
he at that time and i learned of them
did a study of
how
gases in the atmosphere trap heat
and he explained how much the heat
trapping power was of various gases
including carbon dioxide he explained
very clearly how much carbon dioxide
would contribute to global warming as it
increased so this was known way back
then i knew it as a 14 year old
and the mechanism is obvious you can sit
behind a
plate glass window
when the sun is shining and feel
everything heat up around you the
greenhouse effect
so it's it's simple it's obvious it's
got plenty of science behind it what do
people do now
well
they create a negative externality by
polluting people drive around in cars
and dump co2 into the atmosphere and
each individual is convenienced by being
able to drive around in his car
but he
contributes to a global problem a
problem that won't come back perhaps to
haunt him
if he doesn't live long enough
or maybe gradual so gradually doesn't
notice it but everybody together is busy
contributing this major externality
to the world
which leads to a second
little mental model
it's called the tragedy of the commons
that's a pretty famous thing by a guy
named garrett harden
and the simple example is you've got a
village with a little green in the
middle and it's got a lot of grass
growing and only a few people live in
the village
so one guy has sheep and he lets his
sheep graze on the green and there's
plenty of grass so that's not a problem
a few more people move in they get some
sheep they turn them loose on the green
pretty soon
they're too many sheep for the green
it's all eaten up
so each person acts in his own
self-interest
but
collectively
what they do is against the common good
so that's another little
mental model or idea
so their whole collection of these
these things that are out there that are
very valuable
for thinking purposes
one collection is there's a 50
a 50 item collection that came out under
inc period on the internet about from
elon musk it's quite good
there's also charlie munger's book
poor charlie's almanac yeah which has a
lot of these things embedded in it one
of my favorites is
it has a strange name
of uh fundamental attribution error
and
i didn't like the name i said charlie
why are you calling this fundamental
attribution error
well
charlie actually just picked it up from
sociology and psychology that's what
they call it
and
i thought it's a terrible name you
should call something else but as i
thought about it some more i just said
it's actually not a bad dame after all
roughly speaking
what it does
is
it's a human tendency
to
make assumptions that are not
fully justified by the evidence for
instance you go to lunch
and
the person you invited doesn't show up
so you begin to
speculate well
maybe he just forgot he's a forgetful
guy or uh maybe
since we had a little quarrel two weeks
ago maybe that was it maybe he's just
mad he's gonna show me or something of
that sort you start making enough stuff
to try to explain it
but you don't have the evidence for it
it turns out that he had a car actually
on the way and he's busy dealing with
all the fall off in a car accident
two hours later you find out what
actually happened and
it's too bad and he apologizes profusely
but you didn't have any idea what
actually happened you just started
making stuff up
that is something that humans do over
and over and we're wired for it it's
it's evolutionary
it ties into a famous book thinking fast
and slow daniel kahneman yes exactly
so he has an example there of you're in
the forest
and
you hear a roar
you don't stop to find out where the
roar is coming from you run up the
nearest tree because it might be a
lion in fact it might be something
entirely different but you don't take
any chances you you react
and if it's not a lion you've made
fundamental attribution here you
attributed to being a lion when it
wasn't
but it saved your life often when when
it wasn't an attribution error so
that ties in with something else which
is learning how to think
if you
think fast
it's kind of emotionally from the gut
responding without really reflecting
you will make a lot of mistakes
sometimes though it's a way of saving
your life for example somebody else fire
you're you're at the door of the theater
you run out the door
immediately before you find out whether
there is a fire
that might or might not have been but
running out the door before this time to
reflect in which case it might be too
late is a good thing to do
but i hold it open for everybody else
too as i run out
and i just want to mention a few things
on the externalities piece and thinking
about the
say unintended
secondary or tertiary effects on the
collective there can also be
positive
externalities
or externally benefit in an instance
like if you were to buy fire insurance
for your house your your neighbor might
be a little bit safer right so it can it
can go both ways that's a good example
and it's one that actually
i was a real life experience for me
right here oh no kidding we had a fire
here wildfire a couple of months ago we
all had to evacuate
and
i have chub and they have
wildfire insurance
and so i have that and so chop actually
had a water truck out here which
protected not only me but lots of other
people in the neighborhood
is the next step after identifying these
externalities for instance in the case
of the construction site
thinking about
how to
somehow create and enforce
incentives
such that
someone is acting to the benefit of the
collective for instance the construction
site where someone's not spending five
dollars but it costs individuals who are
affected five hundred dollars to replace
a given tire i'm sure there are a
million different examples of this is
does that then lead to a study of
incentives
yes that's a good point
that if somebody creates an externality
that's negative
a good thing to do is to tax it what
we've learned is if you tax something
you get less of it
so
let's take carbon for example if you tax
carbon
you'll get less of it in the air
so a carbon tax is the rational logical
solution to the
whole
pollution problem all you have to do is
make the tax big enough and
people find other ways to do things than
pollute with carbon
however that leads to another thought
principle which is
the difference between rational
solutions to social problems
a rational solution is one that is
generally good for almost everybody
as opposed to a select few
you can have rational solutions to
social problems but you often can't get
them implemented
so you also have to think about what can
you actually accomplish politically
and there's a great book about that
there's a professor at yale
the strolling professor
of political science ian shapiro i
happen to listen
i listen to podcasts yours included when
i go for my walks
and
his course was
one of the ones i listened to it's
absolutely great it talks about how to
actually get something done politically
and we've seen
that
for example the biden administration has
had great difficulty getting very much
of what it wants to do past
and it could learn a lot from this
professor who has a lot of good things
to tell them he has a book called
the wolf at the door which
is fairly recent which basically
explains the things that i learned in
his political science course
a few months ago and it tells you how to
form coalitions that can win
and how to pass things that will stay in
place for example social security stayed
in place
because it had a strong
constituency that it created right away
and that constituency was going to
defend it forever after
and it's politically
even though
some politicians and occasional
political parties have tried to destroy
it they have not been successful because
the consistency is so embedded and so
strong now
so anyhow he has uh
a clear description of how you can
actually get things done and he believes
i think that you can make incremental
progress
discouraging as though it seems these
days by doing
the right way of putting uh coalitions
together
and
defending against
blocking coalitions so it's a very
insightful course anybody who wants to
get something done evolutionarily is i
would recommend reading his book and i
might say
we're in a crisis of democracy now in my
opinion
and we have simplistically we have three
paths there's devolution which i think
oh we're undergoing now
there's evolution which i hope
is the way things work out in which we
fix things and things get better and
there's revolution which is extremely
ugly and unpleasant
and one of your
previous interviewees ray dalio has a
book that i would i think is very well
worth reading even though it's a tough
slog and maybe i'd uh change the writing
a bit but
you know it's it's a real contribution
to thinking about the
crisis that we're going through now
and it talks about the
changing world order
i think that's the name of the book and
the rise of
china as an empire and the decline of
united states as an empire and i think
that
we have some serious thinking to do we
can't just sit back on our laurels and
say we've been so great
we've been uh the world's superpower and
hope that it's going to last we have to
do things differently
so anyhow that
i'd recommend that
i also would second that recommendation
francis fukuyama has also some fantastic
writing
that is that is worth exploring and i
have that dalio book within 15 feet of
me here where i sit right now
and
you know as speaking as someone who
studied also
in china myself at a pretty pretty
fascinating time to be there i was
around
in beijing at two universities in 1996
and i've tracked things pretty closely
since that
it's definitely worthwhile to read up
also on the
history of china because that is going
to and is coming to bear as we speak on
the entire
three-dimensional chess of geopolitics
which is
fascinating and also at times terrifying
certainly
let me ask you if i may
what other investors aside from warren
buffett
impress you and they could be
people who are no longer actively
investing they could be current
but are there any other investors who
come to mind who have
particularly impressed you outside of
outside of buffett and the reason i ask
for people who are wondering is
related to what you said earlier that by
studying investing by participating in
investing you get to stress test
and look at how other people stress test
thinking and cognitive biases and so on
is there any anyone who comes to mind
for you outside of outside of buffett
there are people in the hedge fund world
who have done remarkable jobs at various
times but they're not
accessible
to your
listeners or to most people for example
let's take
jim simons of renaissance right
renaissance partners is basically a
private operation at this point
but it's been extraordinarily successful
uses phds and computers and math and
code breaking and so forth and it has
from around
1989 or 90 on been spectacular in its
performance probably the best
risk adjusted record
in the world from that time forward
and for people who want to read more
about jim simons there's a book called
the man who solved to the market which
is uh which is a good read although
uh you're probably not going to be able
to as as you mentioned emulate the sort
of quant approach that that he is taking
for a million and one reasons but
absolutely fascinating story
any other names who come to mind
well i'm trying to think of who i would
give money to to invest
i don't have anybody now that i'd give
money to to invest there are a few good
hedge funds around but
they take too much
for the general partner and leave too
little for a limited partner
and they also generate
income that is
highly taxed
if you're a taxable investor
so
they're only good for
non-profits at this point
for tax-exempt investors
what about past investors say
in decades past who you would have given
money to willingly does does anyone come
to mind i did give money to ken
griffin's citadel
for
from the time it started i think
i was investor number one after wow
frank meyer who was the other general
partner with ken griffin
frank meyer was a long time friend of
mine from the past so that's how i
learned about it
and i actually had jen griffin out to
the house
when he was about 18 or 19 and
just starting up with frank and talked
to them about how my hedge fund prince
newport worked and we discussed at some
length the idea of profit centers and
subsidiary businesses and i handed them
boxes of prospectuses that were hard to
get on all kinds of convertible
securities
these things would come out when the
securities were issued and then they
would no longer be findable anywhere
they were
just like rare books so i handed to my
whole
collection of cartons of these things
and
so i had a very good ride with him and i
finally
exited
recently because
the
taxes take too big a bite out of the
returns that i get
it's it's just simpler to invest in an
index fund i end up better off than if i
were to remain in a citadel
also it's complicated you get all kinds
of
papers i have four feet of
four feet of paperwork when i finally uh
boxed it all up at the end
that is a lot of paperwork now what i i
know you had the
introduction but what was it at the time
about
ken griffin and and citadel that made it
past muster for you
they were going to follow the exact plan
that i was following when i shut down
prince newport so that was good
got it and i knew frank
and he was smart and capable and uh ken
seemed very smart and capable and
energetic so they were doing what i
would be doing had i stayed in business
so let's let's talk about staying
staying in business because i had a
question
that i wanted to make sure i touched
upon
and there are a million others that
i would love to talk about but could you
please speak to having
enough you've you've spoken about or at
least written about how your hedge fund
could have taken over your life
and you could have just ended up as a
capital accumulator as uh as your
full-time full-time job plus
how did you make the decision to wind it
down and how do you think about having
enough because that that's not it
doesn't strike me as
something i come across
often with people who are really good at
investing
the way i got into the investment world
i was an academic and i was curious and
i found things interesting and i wasn't
really in there
to get rich i was in there
to deal with interesting math problems
that kept coming up
blackjack roulette was a math physics
problem investing was uh for me lots and
lots of math
so
i i enjoyed that
so i just i just do things i like and
i don't worry about money as my
former sister-in-law once said
do what you love and the money will
follow she wrote a book that title
and uh i said you know that's that's
right
do what you love and the money may
follow and if it does that's fine if it
doesn't you're still doing what you love
and
what's important in life i think
is the journey
and the people
you know and you spend your time with
and
how how you spend your time otherwise
also
so
that's how i looked at things and i
started out as a child of the great
depression so i knew what it was like to
have
basically no money
i used to sleep
four or five hours a night in high
school and get up at two or three in the
morning and deliver newspapers
and i made 25 dollars a month which
seemed like really big money
and i
saved part of that for college and
invested part of it in uh
science equipment
chemistry telescopes electronics and so
forth too just because i like
playing with those things and learning
about them
so
my goal wasn't to make money it was to
have
a good life and enjoy myself and have
fun
and it just so happened that it turned
out a lot of money too
so what i found though in the investment
world is lots of people go in it for the
money and when they do
they keep going and going and going and
it's a validation of them and that they
can't stop
they end up with
oh five or ten
villas
a yacht
a jet
and
even if you let's imagine you have uh
five houses just to take an example
how much of your time you're spending
each house you can't be on average more
than a fifth [ __ ] by math
and you're not going to be in your house
all the time anyhow you can be
vacationing traveling meeting and so on
so maybe it's a sixth or seventh of the
time on average
now some houses are gonna you're gonna
spend more time in it somewhere so you
may spend a tenth or fifteenth of your
time
or another don't have your time almost
in one of those houses so you end up
with a whole lot of stuff to manage and
take care of and
you end up hiring people to do that
so you don't have to do it and then you
have to manage those people
and then you have to hire people to
manage the people who manage the people
and so on it's like running a business
it's terrible
you don't get to enjoy the important
part of your life which is time
did you
have a set point at which point you knew
you're going to exit
the business so to speak or was there a
particular day that prompted a
particular experience that prompted you
to say enough is enough
i want out do you remember what the
catalyst was if there was one
i
wasn't having fun anymore it was turning
into work and i said well i don't need
to do this i have enough wealth i'm
never going to spend at all
why
keep doing this
so i decided to wind it down
it was fun for a long time because there
were challenging problems and i
it was
challenging to
try to figure out new things and to deal
with all the issues that came up but
when it became
bureaucratic and paperwork and uh
a grind where i had to do things i
didn't want to do that was enough it was
time time to go
and
it was the same thing in academia i
loved academia but there were aspects to
it that became burdensome
committee meetings
endless reviews
grant proposals
what i liked was research
and teaching
and the people
that i met there the students and the
faculty that were
smart and challenging
and if it was only that
i'd still be there
but it wasn't only that
and i found other things that were
equally or more fulfilling
so anyhow i just migrate to where where
i want to be
i don't have a set
thing that i have to keep doing
let's explore that a little bit further
nasim talib
who many people will know because of
books like fooled by randomness the
black swan
anti-fragile
wrote the forward to your memoir and
in that he writes about your restraint
not getting caught up in
the
the golden fetters of large structures
multiple offices morning meetings etc
and he highlights
the value or the fact that you value
independence so what what does
independence mean to you and
how did you spend your time after
winding down
the investment
side of things
i spent my time
reading
traveling
exercising
enjoying my family and my friends
and learning
things that i could learn and then it's
also entertaining to
casually manage my investments i might
just interject here that
one of the things that makes you
independent is to accumulate capital
because then the capital can grow on its
own if it's up
simply invested as i described before it
in for example an index fund
and once you have capital then you have
the chance of independence if you have
enough capital it will support you
indefinitely
when you've achieved that goal there's
no point in spending time doing anything
you don't like doing if you can help it
you know i have to do some things you
don't like like gather all your tax
information together every year
or
go in for routine medical appointments
but
is there anything that you are
particularly interested in learning more
about now or in the process of learning
about or looking forward to learning
about
what i've focused on for the last
year or so is reading about
what's going on in american society
what may happen
i don't think we can predict for sure
what's going to happen but we can
map out scenarios we can map out
possibilities we won't get them all
but we can map out quite a few of them
and ask ourselves what will we do with
scenario ace and robs and roc
materializes
and have some sort of preparation and
readiness for that
i won't go into a list of extreme
scenarios except maybe a few you could
have
a
an autocratic country where a minority
pretty much rules everything
and dictates everybody else
you could have a turbulent country where
a large part of the country maybe a
majority is badly upset
and just wants to bust everything up and
start over somehow
so you could have the choices i
described a devolution evolution or
revolution i don't know how it's going
to play out
but
it's worth thinking about
what might happen and whether there's
anything
any of us can do about it
i don't think there's much
an individual can do
on a grand scale
unless he happens to be in a position of
great importance or manages to get
himself in a position of great
importance
but i think there's a lot that an
individual can do on a small scale and i
think the best thing we can do is teach
everybody to think for themselves
so they don't just take what they're
told in the press for example
or in the other forms of the media
the internet
twitter so on they don't just take that
and stop it up and believe it
but they
question it and they ask
whether in fact
it might not be true and what the modis
are the people who are putting these
things out and so forth and when you
think you think for yourself the whole
world changes
and becomes much clearer in my opinion
and you can manage your life much better
fundamental attribution error
learning about things like that
and
putting your own thinking
under examination
ed this has been this has been so fun
and i i know that there are a million
other things we could talk about and
hopefully we'll have a chance to do a
round two at some point
but i wanted to be respectful of your
time and
perhaps begin to bring this to a close
is there anything else that you would
like to
mention or call attention to any request
of my audience that you would like to
make
people can certainly find
you online at edwardo thorpe dot com and
i'll link to that as well as your books
and everything else that we've discussed
in the show notes at tim dot blog
podcast
is there anything else that you would
like to bring up before we
end this round one conversation
i'll tell you one story
that
you've probably read my book
it's about
joseph heller and
kurt vonnegut yes please joseph howler
wrote his famous book cat 22
of which they made a movie
way back
maybe 50 years ago i'm not sure exactly
when but it was
very well known famous at the time and
kurt vonnegut
is well known too for a variety of books
and
joseph heller died
i'm not sure when maybe uh early 2000s
and kurt vonnegut was writing in the new
yorker about him and he said
joseph
heller and i were at a hedge fund moguls
house
i'm not sure if it was a hedge fund
mogul but
somebody very very rich in new york
and i said to joseph heller
you know
you've made a lot of money out of cash
22.
this guy makes as much money
in a day as you're ever going to make
he's got
penthouses and yachts and jets
and villas
and
models falling off his arm and so on
and justin looked back and said you know
i have something he'll never have
kurt vonnegut was puzzled he said what's
that heller said i have enough
and that's something that people who
chase money to the end
don't figure out
that you can have enough
and it's better than not having enough
it's certainly better than never being
stated
staying on that compulsive
track and i i am so endlessly fascinated
by by you your story your lessons
learned
and i really hope we have a chance to
have
another conversation because i
have still so many different notes and
questions that i would i would love to
tackle but we'll we'll leave people
wanting more and
hopefully we will make make time to have
that second conversation but thank you
so much for taking the time today ed
it's been uh it's been a real joy to
spend this time with you well i enjoyed
it very much a pleasure to meet you and
now i know that since i'm on your
podcast my wife will listen to me
well
one can hope one can hope one can hope
and everybody listening thank you for
tuning in as always and until next time
try not to act like a scared rabbit and
be just a little bit kinder than you
think you need to be
and
as always thank you for tuning in thank
you
you